a obtenu ce michel laugier
33 voix les images ont presque 13 ans
jour pour jour ce 11 octobre 2004 à
michel laugier voit son parcours
politique concrètement débuté il devient
alors le maire de montigny le bretonneux
à l'âge de 46 ans
ému et tendrement ému parce que toute la
soirée j'ai pensé un homme j'ai pensé à
nicolas bour celui que je viens de
remplacer lui qui a siégé à la tête de
ce conseil municipal pendant 27 ans et
demi d'écouter ça fait un drôle d'effet
de se retrouver dans son fauteuil en
fauteuil de maire que le journaliste de
formation aura donc occupé pendant 13
ans et qui l'aura vu progressivement
grandir dans la cour politique
yvelinoise réélu maire en 2008 et 2014
michel laugier devient la même année
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines sortie vent de
fierté sont ils ont aussi de vivre une
étape importante puisque c'est
historique que président de droite
préside aux destinées aujourd'hui dans
la communauté d'agglomération et son
histoire politique michel logique
continue de l'écrire en 2015 candidat de
la droite pour les élections
départementale sur le canton de montigny
le bretonneux il réussi à reconquérir un
territoire réservé à la gauche depuis
1994 lorsqu'on gagne un canton pour
lequel on est challenger et ça fait
plaisir en plus le gagner d'une si belle
façon je crois si de grandes
satisfactions
élu sénateur michel logis et siègera
désormais dans une chambre connu pour
être plus ouverte au compromis politique
une caractéristique qui devrait lui
correspondre lui le parlementaire de
droite qui n'a jamais été encarté ni à
l'ump ni aux républicains
[Applaudissements]